Моя любовь Субтитры создавал DimaTorzok Hausaufgabe von mir an die Hörer, wenn ihr Organist in der Kirche seid, dann müsst ihr beim Abendmahl, ich glaube das ist es bei den Protestanten, bei uns war es halt die heilige Kommunion, wenn man die entgegen nimmt, wenn man sich in Reihung Lied aufstellt, um die Hostie zu mampfen, dann wird immer nebenbei improvisiert der Organist immer so ein bisschen was. Und ich finde toll, wenn das der Song ist, den er improvisiert, während der Hostienverspeisung. Finde ich sehr, sehr gut. Vielen, vielen Dank an dieses fantastische, epische Orgel-Intro, das beste Instrument der Welt von Martin, wen ihr gerade schon habt sprechen hören, ist natürlich Stefan Teats me, teats me, say that you, teats me, it's the Titzer. It's the Titzer und Will, Will, Will, Nurek, wo den Will ist auf dem Start und brabbelt auch schon feuchtfrühlich drauflos. Freut euch, die frohe Kunde ist verbreitet, denn es ist das Podcast-Ufo, das ihr gerade anhört. Schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid. Amen. Amen. Ja, Orgel, das beste Instrument aller Zeiten. Ich habe ausgerufen bei alles Mögliche, falls damals Rocket Beans TV war es das beste Instrument. Orgel, habe gewonnen. Wegen Interstellar? Ich habe nämlich starke Interstellar-Vibes bekommen. Ja, das ist wirklich so. Also die Orgel wird ja so selten eingesetzt, dass sie direkt mit einem bestimmten Genre assoziiert wird. Sci-Fi? Ja, Sci-Fi, davor war es Vampir. Ja, das stimmt, also religiös war es immer. Es war immer religiös. Das kriegst du nicht mehr raus. Das kriegst du nicht aus der Orgel raus. Nee. Man kriegt die Orgel in die Kirche, man kriegt sie nicht wieder raus. Logistisch und metaphorisch. Ja, und metaphorisch. Das stimmt schon. Aber ja, ich habe auch ausgerufen, dass ich gerne mal auf eine Orgel die fabelhafte Welt, die Amelie spielen möchte. Und bis jetzt haben sich Leute gemeldet, aber die Orgeln sind halt immer wahnsinnig weit weg. Kennt ihr das? Heiße Orgeln aus deiner Nähe wollen Kontakt mit dir aufnehmen, kriegt man selten die Nachricht. Sind die per Definition nicht super nah in deiner Nähe es gibt so viele Kirchen in Deutschland. Naja gut, aber du brauchst ja auch
einen Organisten, der was drauf hat. Ich habe beim besten
Willen, und ich habe es wirklich gewollt,
ich hätte wirklich einen guten Willen,
aber selbst mal beim besten Willen habe ich nicht
verstanden, wie Orgeln funktionieren, weil die
waren ja sogar schon im Mittelalter am Start
und haben rumgepfiffen. Wie geht das?
Weil das sind riesige Pfeifen.
Ja, du hast irgendwo
einen riesen Luftbehälter und das ist sogar eine bestimmte Art von Motor.
Ich check's nicht.
Das ist eine bestimmte Art von Motor, der so ganz langsam sich bewegt oder so.
Und der drückt dann die Luft durch und das ist so wie so ein Dudelsack.
Wir reden von Zeiten, da gab es noch keine Autos.
Genau, ja, aber da gibt es schon so mit so Gewichten und Hoch und Seilzug und sowas und ich Reihe Wörter aneinander. Ja, alle cool klingen. Flaschenzug, alles Heizvoll. Ja, Flaschenzug, Seilzug, Gleichgewicht der Kräfte, sowas halt. Und dann hast du ja wie beim Dudelsack, hast du ja den dicken Beutel. Du hast keinen Beutel. Ja, genau, das ist halt ein ganzer Raum. Also was beim Dudelsack ein Beutel ist, ist halt bei der Orgel halt ein ganzer Raum,
wo dann auch Leute manchmal untergebracht werden,
der ist voller Luft, wo dann oben so ein
großer Blasebalg runterdrückt. Ist so ein bisschen
wie die Star Wars Szene, wo dann so die
Wände näher kommen, wenn der Organist dann wieder
mal einen Solo ballert, werden da
alle die Ministranten alle zutaten.
Du hattest mich ja bei Flaschenzug, Seilzug,
trägerter Masse. Und Star Wars.
Und Star Wars, da komme ich dann irgendwie, jetzt verstehe ich einigermaßen, wie Orgel funktionieren. Ja, wir hatten sogar eine Orgel in unserer Universität, da hingen auch diese Orgelflöten rum, hat aber nie jemand drauf gespielt, vielleicht weil man den Raum verloren hat, man weiß nicht, wer dem Raum gehört. Ben Hur. Ja. Der Film, an den ich mich nicht erinnern konnte. Nein, Ben Hur war der Film. Aber nicht der alte Film, das 2016er-Remake. Habe ich neu geguckt? Habe ich noch mal geguckt? Es gibt kein Remake von Ben Hur. Nein, du meinst Clash of the Titans. Nein, ist mir angefallen, ich habe die ganze Woche, saß ich mit hochrotem Kopf und dieser Denkgeste auf meinem Sofa, habe überlegt, was war das für ein Film, Ben Hur. Ja, Stefan Tietz hat letzte Woche von einem antiken Film erzählt, der ihm nicht so gut gefallen hat. Er fand ihn so langweilig, dass er ihn vergessen hat. Er war so langweilig, ich hab ihn vergessen, ich hab ihn wieder geguckt und wieder vergessen. Und jetzt hab ich schon zum dritten Mal geguckt und konnte mich jetzt wieder daran erinnern, Ben Hur, der neue Ben Hur. Und das ist auch für mich so ein bisschen eine Memo, guckt den nicht nochmal. Ja. Ist ein bisschen doof, weil man seine eigenen Podcasts oft nicht mehr anhört, aber das ist kein guter Film. Aber ist das der Name der Hauptfigur, Ben Hur, ist Hur der Nachname? Ich weiß es nicht mehr, ich habe keine Erinnerung an den Film. Gibt es da so eine Kindervariante, Benny Hur? Benny Hur. Könnte man auch machen, aber ja, kann ich mir gut vorstellen, würde ich mir im Leben nicht anschauen. Grauenvolles Remake, glaube ich. Aber kannst du aktiv denken, also wirklich, weil du sagst, du hast mit hochrotem Kopf, saßt du da, also wenn du jetzt angenommen, du hast eine Kiste, die musst du hochheben und die stellt sich als schwerer raus, als du dachtest, weil irgendein Trottel denkt, er müsste seine ganzen Bücher umziehen, die er nie wieder liest, und du denkst dir beim Umzug schon, lassen wir dir einfach hier, es würde gar nicht auffallen, wenn diese Kiste Bücher fehlt, weil du liest eh nicht, ich kenne dich. Was soll das für Bücher sein? Was ist das für ein Buch? Leute, die dir irgendwie, Bücher, die dir geschenkt haben, was ist das für ein Buch? Lass es mal den Karton aufmachen, lass es einfach mal den Karton aufmachen. Guck mal hier, Sebastian Fitzek, was ist das? Ja, was ist das? Hast du gelesen? Hast das gelesen? Naja, das habe ich halt zu Weihnachten bekommen, das lese ich noch.
Das liest du noch?
Natürlich, das habe ich halt von meiner Tante zu Weihnachten bekommen.
Wie viele Bücher liest du im Jahr?
Also, naja, was heißt Bücher? Ich habe das Booklet von meinem Flachbildschirm zur Hälfte gelesen.
Hast du jemals Buch gelesen, was deine Tante dir geschenkt hat?
Ähm, Emil.
So, wir lassen es hier.
Nein, das sind meine Bücher, das kannst du ja nicht machen, du kannst ja nicht den Karton anzünden mit den Büchern. So, und falls du das da der Karton ist schwerer als man denkt, dann kannst du sagen, nochmal extra Dampf auf die Muskeln, nochmal mehr Kraft brauche ich, gib alles, ja so richtig, dann werden die Zähne zusammengekniffen. Die Frage, die ich stellen möchte, ist, ob es auch gedanklich geht. Genau, geht das beim Denken. Weil oft fallen mir Dinge nicht ein und ich denke mir so, jetzt mehr Kraft bitte aufs Gehirn, mehr Energie, aber bringt das wirklich was oder nicht? Das habe ich mir überlegt beim Schachspielen jetzt, beim Zugs, beim Turnier, weil man ja Ja, häufig im Profischach sieht man so Denkgesten. Ja. Und dann fassen die sich mit so zwei Fingern an die Schläfe und so und überlegen härter. Und die spielen ja auch gut. Ja. Und dann habe ich mir auch manchmal überlegt, beim Spielen sollte ich jetzt nicht besser nachdenken. Und dann, aber dann ist die Frage, dann bedingt sich das gegenseitig, weiß ich nicht, da habe ich jedenfalls angefangen, dann auch meine Finger in die Schläfe zu legen, aber da habe ich so sehr darüber nachgedacht, über die Geste, die ich gerade mache, dass man sich wiederum nicht so wirklich konzentriert. Ich glaube, das muss authentisch aus dir herauskommen. Du musst den Willen aufbringen, jetzt doller nachzudenken. Fokus, fokus. Na, ich glaube, schon was rausdrücken. Ich glaube, du kannst schon nochmal 10% aus deinem Gehirn rausdrücken.
Man sagt, das Gehirn ist ein Muskel, aber ich glaube nicht, dass es ein Muskel ist.
Ja, vor allem es kann ja nicht grösser werden.
Die Muskeln sind ja über dem Knochen beim Menschen.
Das heißt, die Muskeln können beliebig gross werden.
Ja, meiner Erfahrung nach nicht, aber ja.
Ja gut, aber das Gehirn ist ja im Schädel, also kann es nicht grösser werden. Aber es kann sich besser vernetzen. Flaschenzug, Gleichgewicht der Kräffe, das Equilibrium, E ist gleich im C-Quadrat. Das stimmt schon. Es kann sich besser vernetzen. Die Synapsen können sich besser zusammenfinden. Ich meine, du hast jetzt die andere rhetorischen Kniff, du hast einfach, während du redest, die Hand zu einem Greifarm geformt und greifst damit in die Luft, als würdest du das verdeutlichen, aber es kommt bei mir nicht an. Kommt es bei dir nicht an? Wohingegen Käfer, da ist der Muskel ja auch unterm Knochen, die haben ja diese Panzer, das heißt ein Käfer kann so viel trainieren, wie er will.
Wenn du irgendwie so einen Maikäfer pumpen siehst im Gym, kannst du sagen, hey, leg die, leg die.
Was?
Leg die.
Sorry, ich habe Musik.
Ich höre gerade den B. Maier-Soundtrack. Sorry, leg die Handel weg.
Leg mal kurz die Handel weg.
Was?
Warum?
Du bist ein Käfer.
Schau, ich pumpen kann.
Nein, nein, nein, das bringt nichts.
Ich kann das dreihundertfache in meinem Körpergewicht tragen.
Du hast die. Ich kann dich hochheben. Die 20-Gramm-Handlung, tu die mal kurz weg. Dein Muskel ist unter deinem Chitin-Panzer. Der kann gar nicht wachsen. Der kann nicht wachsen. Was? Ich habe dir hier so ein Biologiebuch für Kinder mitgebracht. Ja, zeig mal. Der Maikäfer. Der Maikäfer ist ein lieber süsser Käfer, der jeden Mal auftaucht. Süss, süss, süss. Er Hot! Nein, nein, niedlicher, denn guckt euch den niedlichen, putzigen Marienkäfer mal an. Warum? Zeig mal. Wie süss der ist, wie klein der ist, der sieht platzen? Ja, an diesem Zeitpunkt war alles egal. Ich bin mit diesen Holzbeatsballschlägern, habe ich mir einen Weg durch die Schwärme gekämpft.
Das war insane.
Ich weiß gar nicht, bis heute nicht, ob ich das geträumt habe oder ob das passiert ist.
Weil es war einfach, der Strand an der Ostsee war orange.
Der Strand war komplett, du hast keinen Sand mehr gesehen, weil überall Marienkäfer waren.
Wie viele Marienkäfer hast du eigenhändig getötet?
Gib mir eine Zahl.
Über 100.000.
100.000 Marienkäfer hast du getötet.
Es war ein Witz. komplett, du hast keinen Sand mehr gesehen, weil überall Marienkäfer waren. Wie viele Marienkäfer hast du eigenhändig getötet? Gib mir eine Zahl. Über 100.000. 100.000 Marienkäfer hast du getötet. Aber es war egal. Die waren überall. Du konntest ja gar nicht mehr, allein wenn du einen Strandspazieren gemacht hast, hast du per Definition einen Holocaust begangen. Die waren überall, das war insane. Es ist eigentlich die perfekte biblische Plage, eine Plage von extrem niedlichen Tieren. Stell dir vor, Kätzchen und Hundewelpen gäbe es zu Millionen. Und die sind einfach im Weg und man kommt nicht voran. Und irgendwann fängt man an, die einfach tot zu treten. Und die miau, miau, einfach batz, batz. Ja, weil auch Marienke, wir sind ja wahnsinnig süss. Und eigentlich für sich genommen findet man die toll. Die kündigen den Sommer an, die landen auf dir, haha, süss, alles süss. Aber in rauen Mengen. Ja, Pünktchen drauf. Pünktchen. Manche haben mehr, manche weniger. Was bedeutet das? Würfeln die die aus? Oder ist das das Alter, Alterspunkte? Aber das Bild ist auch Unsinn, dass nach genau einem Jahr kommt der nächste Punkt. Ja, vor allem, dann kommt der nächste Punkt und alle anderen müssen ein Stück zur Seite rücken. Sorry, hier bin ich bereits ich als Punkt. Oder schreiben die von links nach rechts und wissen im Vorhinein schon. Das ist wie wenn man eine Geschenkkarte schreibt. Liebe Grüße, dein Floren... Ja, und dann die Kurve in die Ecke. Das heißt aber auch, wenn die Punkte sehr groß sind, weiß der Marine-Käfer, dass er nicht so alt werden kann. Ich glaube, das Leben eines Marine-Käfer ist die absolute Hölle. An dem Strand damals war es die absolute Hölle. Nicht nur, weil die sich auch gegenseitig bestimmt mega genervt haben. Das frage ich mich immer. Haben Ameisen manchmal das Gefühl, hier ist es gerade zu crowded, hier ist es zu viel los, hier ist es zu voll, hier ist es mir zu voll. Ja, kann schon sein. Wir als Menschen, klar, wenn du so einen Vogelblick hast auf Tokio, keine Ahnung, dann laufen wir ja auch alle so rum wie so ein Insektenschwarm.
Aber da hat ja jeder einzelne Mensch gerade das Gefühl, hier ist mir gerade zu voll.
Haben Ameisen das Gefühl auch oder so ein Bienenschwarm, die alle aneinander reiben, denken die, oh Gott, hier ist schon wieder, ich muss hier raus, ich muss hier raus.
Ja, ja, nee, absolut, ich muss hier wieder raus.
Hier sind zu viele Leute.
Hier sind zu viele.
Mit wem redest du? Mit Paul. Ich bin nicht Paul.
Ich bin nicht Paul. Ach so. Alle gleich aus.
Alle sagen im Gleichklang,
ich muss mal raus, ich muss hier mal raus.
Aber dann gibt es ja einzelne Ameisen, die dann auch abhauen und rausgehen
und dann auch
einfach sich einen kurzen Moment nehmen.
Keine Ameise
geht mal raus. Nehmt sich mal
einen kurzen Moment, eine kleine Auszeit, eine kleine Raucherpause, natürlich. Du siehst doch, ich glaube, egal, Ameisen gelten als sehr produktiv, was ich gerne auch mal in Frage stellen möchte. Ich glaube, du hast in jeder Tierspezies hast du es lecker. Du hast Leute, die irgendwie kurz hinterm Nest stehen, auch der Vogel hinterm Nest mit einer Zigarette und einfach kurz sagt, ich brauche einen Moment, ich brauche einfach kurz einen Moment. Hey Fips, wir tragen ja nicht die Blätter hier, wir tragen die Blätter von A nach B. Ja, ich komme gleich. Wir tragen die Blätter sinnlos von A nach B, wir brauchen dich. Du, ich komme gleich. Was machst du da? Geht schon mal vor, ich bin, ich komme gleich hinterher. Was hast du da in der Hand? Was hast du da in der Hand, Fips? Ne, ich muss hier hinten noch ganz kurz was schauen. Geht schon mal vor, ich komme gleich nach. Was ist eine Zigarette? Ich bin übrigens nicht. Du wirst doch nicht hier einfach rausgehen, um zu rauchen. Ich brauche eine kurze Pause, Mensch. In den ganzen Nacht. Pause! Wir sind Armeis, wir machen keine Pause. Ach ja, gut, ich brauche einfach einen Moment für mich. Du brauchst einen Moment für dich? Ja, ich bin übrigens auch nicht Fips. Alles für die Königin? Du bist nicht Fips? Nein, ich bin Rudolfus. Rudolfus? Ja. Mein Name ist Argon, alles für die Königin. Ja, alles für die Königin, gib mir eine Sekunde. Wieso gibt die, wir müssen doch arbeiten. Was willst du machen, gehst du Königin und sagst, Rudolfus arbeite nicht mit, woher will sie wissen, dass ich Rudolfus bin? Ich hab sie noch nie gesehen. Wir sehen alle exakt gleich aus. Woher willst du wissen, wer die Königin ist? Sag ich, ich bin nicht die Königin. Nein, die Königin ist Gross und Flügel. Sagt wer? Das Biologiebuch, was gerade vom Himmel gefallen. Das verdammte Scheiss-Biologiebuch für Kinder. Man darf nie zu einem Ameisenhügel gehen und denen das Biologiebuch so zeigen. Die werden zu schlau. Was, wir leben zwei Tage? Fuck it, ich arbeite nicht mehr. Bin raus hier. Und ich glaube, auch wenn du weisst, dass du das 300-fache deines Körpergewichts tragen kannst, dann erlis damit diese Fähigkeit auch. Ja, stimmt, nur wenn man es wirklich will. Ich glaube, das ist das Moloch des Menschen, dass er zu viel über sich selbst weiß. Du musst nicht in dem Podcast, wo die Hausaufgabe entstanden ist, die Hausaufgabe erfüllen. Ich meine, so eine Ameise weiß quasi gar nichts über sich selbst. Die meisten Tiere wissen nichts über sich selbst. Nur der Mensch weiß so viel über sich selbst. Wie funktioniert die. Wir wissen zum Beispiel, was in unserem Körper drin ist. Leber, Milz, Niere, Herz, viele Knochen. Ich wusste mal die Anzahl. Menge Knochen, 20 plus. Wohin ging so ein Wiesel, wenn du den fragst, was ist in dir drin? Kleinere Wiesel, die meine Arme bewegen. Also wahrscheinlich noch mal
kleine, wenn ich was esse,
dann fressen kleinere Wiesel
das und legen die das
dann in meine Armenwiesel.
Die wissen nicht mehr, wie sie aussehen, weil die sich selten
im Spiegel sehen.
Das stimmt, das darf man nie machen.
Ein Tier fotografieren und denen das Foto zeigen.
Die sagen, was?
So sehe ich aus?
Das werden die nicht sagen, weil die das das Prinzip Foto eigentlich checken, die werden
sagen, was zeigst du mir da für ein Bild? Die werden ja nicht fragen, die checken ja auch
nicht mal, wenn sie vom Spiegel stehen, checken sie ja nicht mehr, dass sie selber sind.
Aber sorry, können wir mal kurz, kann die Wissenschaft mal endlich das Maul aufmachen
und mal sagen, was checken Tiere? Können wir das kurz klären? Weil ich bin ja, ja ja haben wir drüber gesprochen, ich bin Instagram real süchtig und da gibt es manchmal so Filter, die halt dann über dem Gesicht liegen und dann sieht der aus wie eine Maus. Gott, Tim, du bist so abgedrückt. Der ist verrückt. Du hast dich radikalisiert, aber auf eine negative, auf eine gefährliche Art. Ja, auf eine niedliche Art. Ja, du hast dich verniedlich radikalisiert. Und dann gucken die manchmal mit ihren Haustieren in ihr Handy, also wie ein Spiegel, die sehen ihre eigene Kamera. Und dann kriegt sozusagen die Besitzerin und der Hund den Filter. Kriegen Schreck. Und der Hund kriegt dann total Panik und läuft weg. Und ich denke mir, Moment mal, Instagram Reel, du sagst mir gerade, dass der Hund A versteht, dass er selbst da gerade zu sehen ist in dem Handy. Zweitens versteht, dass da das, was mit diesem Hund im Handy passiert, mit ihm selber passiert. Er denkt dann, Moment mal, ich bin jetzt eine Maus, dann auch noch Angst hat, weil er keine Maus sein will und dann wegläuft. Und dann den Gangnam Style aufführt, das soll er alles irgendwie machen. Und dann noch sagt, liken und kommentieren bitte. Also das sind so viele Elemente. Wahrscheinlich hat der Hund einfach gerade irgendwie einen Vogel gesehen auf dem Balkon und rennt deswegen weg. Also ich kann mir einfach kurz mal sagen, all Biologen der Welt, ganz kurz, was checken Tiere? Es gibt ja das ganz einfache Experiment. Du machst, du stellst ein Tier vor den Spiegel und malst den Punkt, einen roten Punkt auf die Stirn. Und wenn sie versuchen, den wegzuwischen, checken sie, dass sie selber, da haben sie ein Bewusstsein. Das kann man ja bei Kleinkindern auch machen. Aber wer sagt, dass das Tier nicht völlig in Ordnung damit ist, dass es einen roten Punkt auf der Stirn hat? Das sind die anderen Tiere. Jetzt schlagen wir so eine Douglas-Adams-Richtung ein. Die Delf sind ja inzwischen cleverer als wir Menschen und sie sind sich darüber im Klaren, dass dieser rote Punkt rein gar nichts macht und die haben auch ähnliche Eitelkeit abgelegt, weil die so krass sind. Oder das als Ehre empfinden und sagen, danke für den roten Punkt. Danke für den roten Punkt, das ist unsere Kultur, unsere jahrtausendlange alten Krokodilkultur. Weil allein die Tatsache, dass ein Tier versucht, den vielleicht wegzuwischen, sagt a, dass das Tier unterscheiden kann zwischen Dingen, die zu der Fellfarbe gehören und nicht, b, was dagegen hat, dass es anders aussieht, als es normalerweise aussieht. Eitelkeit. Also eitel ist, was ja auch schon mal eine starke These ist, wo ich einfach sagen würde, nee, es ist Zufall. Oder CGI, mittlerweile CGI ist ja so weit. Ist ein Problem, ich glaube, die meisten Tiere checken diesen Punkt nicht, korrigiert mich. Oder haben keine Stirn, ist halt auch ein Problem. Aber mittlerweile ist auch alles, was ich in diesem Podcast sage, falsch, hat sich herausgestellt. Nicht nur wurde ich wieder angegangen, weil ich die These aufgestellt habe, dass Italien das einzige Land ist, wo wir Gebiete. Obwohl, das ist vielleicht so eine Sache wie mit Pluto, wo du ja auch jahrelang in der Aufzählung den Pluto vergessen hast und alle gesagt haben, oh, Stefan ist so dumm, der kennt nicht alle Planeten. Plötzlich war Pluto kein Planet mehr und Stefan hatte die ganze Zeit Recht gehabt. Wer ist jetzt dumm? Wer ist jetzt dumm? Wer ist jetzt dumm? Gut, jetzt vergesse ich immer Jupiter, aber gut. Gut, vielleicht ist er der Nächste, der raus ist. Gut, es ist ein Riesenplanet, deswegen zählt er nicht mehr zu den normalen Planeten. Pluto ist zu klein, Jupiter ist zu groß. Aber kann ja auch einer sein, dass einer abhaut, oder? Was ich jedenfalls gesagt habe, letzte Staffel, Podcast UFO, letzte Woche, da habe ich gesagt, dass ein Drittel der Weltliteratur über Steuerrecht in deutscher Sprache verfasst ist. Stefan Tietze debunked! Wir haben uns zehn Minuten darüber amüsiert, stellt sich heraus, das ist ein Fehler. Du glaubst doch jeden Scheiß, oder? Habe ich gelesen, irgendwo habe ich geglaubt. Du glaubst alles, was man dir sagt. Ich glaube alles, was man im Instagram Reel sagt. Was Schäferhunde in Instagram Reels sagen. Aber was ist der tatsächliche Anteil der deutschen Steuerliteratur? Ja, da war so hinter der Paywall bei Bild. Ja. Weiß ich nicht. Sagen wir nicht so viel. Also du kannst dich nicht korrigieren. Revision ohne Korrektur. Aber es gibt einen Artikel, der das debunkt. Es gibt einen Artikel, wo die Überschrift einigermaßen war nach dem Motto, es ist ein Fehler, anzunehmen, dass ein Drittel der Gewaltliteratur in Steuerrecht deutsch sind. Also irgendjemand musste sich mit diesem Urban Myth mal auseinandersetzen und aktiv dazu Stellung beziehen. Es gibt aber noch keinen Artikel, der sagt, nein, Italien ist nicht das einzige Land, wo wir Städte und Gebiete mit deutschen Namen ersetzen. Wir lassen das einfach. Du bist wie so eine Forschungseinrichtung, die seit Jahrhunderten einfach behauptet, Wasser kocht bei 70 Grad. Und dann testen sie es und nein, ja, lassen sie es nochmal testen. Einfach schon seit Jahrzehnten. Die Forschungsgelder reichen noch und sie kommen einfach nicht voran. Ein Kumpel von mir hat extreme Probleme gehabt, er sich doch mit seiner Freundin gestritten, weil sie der Meinung war, dass Wasser schneller kocht, wenn es kalt ist. Reverse-engineered, falsch reverse-engineered von dem Fakt, dass warmes Wasser schneller gefriert. Aus irgendeinem Grund gefriert warmes Wasser schneller. Ja.
Oder nicht?
Also ich habe das auch mal gehört, ich meine, wie gesagt, vielleicht sollten wir davon Abstand nehmen, Thesen, vielleicht sollten wir einfach nur noch Tiergeräusche machen in diesem Podcast und einfach keine Thesen aufstellen. These? Okay, wir sollten keine Thesen mehr aufstellen. Nein, ich habe mal gehört, dass es so ist, dass wenn du lauferarmes Wasser einfrierst, wenn du kaltes Wasser einfrierst, dann friert oben eine Schicht zu, wie so ein See, und diese Schicht ist dann wie eine Jacke, die dazu führt, dass die Kälte nicht mehr an den Rest des Wassers kommt. Macht perfect sense, ja. Aber warum passiert das nicht auch bei lauwarmem Wasser? Ja, wahrscheinlich schon. Also ich glaube, da kühlt es dann gleichmässiger ab oder so, ich weiß es nicht, aber tatsächlich Bill Nye wurde diese Frage mal gestellt, The Science Guy, Bill Nye, The Science Guy. Jetzt Bill Nye, erklär doch bitte mal, wie ist das denn? Gefriert, warmes Wasser, schneller als kaltes. Und weißt du, was er gesagt hat? Probiert es doch einfach aus. Nehmt doch einfach zwei Tassen, eine lauwarme, eine kalte und stellt es in den Gefrierschrank. Schonört ihr auf mich den Scheiß zu fragen, weil der Mann ist ja Physiker, der lebt ja das Experiment, der sagt, was hilft das denn, wenn ich euch das jetzt sage, probiert es doch selber aus, er forscht die Welt, er forscht die Welt. Moment, nein, nein, das kann ich nicht so stehen lassen, mein erster Impuls war zu sagen, ja, der Mann hat Recht, wir machen selber nichts mehr, wir gucken uns immer YouTube-Videos an, statt selber mal zu erleben. Ja, das kann ich nie so stehen lassen. Mein erster Impuls war zu sagen, ja, der Mann hat Recht. Ja, natürlich hat er Recht. Wir machen selber nichts mehr. Wir gucken uns immer YouTube-Videos an, anstatt selber mal zu erleben. Ja, das ist ein Nachmittag, das Experiment. Der Grund, warum es immer wieder vergessen ist, weil wir es nur gucken. Wenn wir es aber selber machen, das Experiment, dann würden wir es nicht vergessen. Aber ich dachte, dann dachte ich, was ist denn Bill Nye für ein arrogantes Arschloch? Das ist sein ganzer Job, sein ganzes Vermögen. Er ist Multimilliardär, weil... Warum das denn? Weiß ich nicht. Er ist doch ein bekannter Physiker, ist der Science Guy, hey. Ja. Aber der wird doch wahnsinnig viel Geld haben, weil er Experimente macht. Er macht ja nicht seinen Job kaputt, wenn er sagt, ihr macht es doch, fragt mich nicht diese Scheiße. Nein, so funktioniert doch Wissenschaft. Es ist seine Aufgabe, die Flamme und Leidenschaft der Wissenschaft zu verbreiten. Und das macht er, indem er den Leuten sagt, hört auf, in Bücher zu gucken. Hört auf, meine Videos zu gucken. Hört auf, meine Videos zu gucken, hört auf, meine Bücher zu kaufen, sondern macht doch selber das Experiment. Das heißt, wenn ihr euch das nächste Mal eine Frage stellt, anstatt zu googeln und den Artikel zu suchen hinter der Paywall oder auf Stefan Tietze zu hören, der am Ende sich eh wieder korrigieren muss und die Korrektur dann wieder korrigieren muss, die Korrektur wieder revidieren muss,
sich dann von der Revision distanzieren muss, und immer so weiter und immer so weiter,
stellt einfach zwei Tassen in den Kühlschrank und schaut, was passiert.
Na los! So gefährlich! Ihr habt's! Los!
Will Neisser doch immer nicht zu Hause nachmachen.
Naja, aber mit Eis, glaube ich, das kriegt man schon noch hin.
Aber tatsächlich, ich habe in letzter Zeit auch für mich Kälte neu entdeckt.
Und weil es ist ja schon verrückt.
Also folgendes Phänomen.
Ich habe angefangen, mich ein bisschen einzulesen in die Welt der gefrorenen Gemüsesorten und habe jetzt haufenweise gefrorenes Gemüse zu Hause und mache mir ab und zu einen schönen Gemüseeintopf.
Und dann ist es ja der Fall, du hast da eine schöne heisse Suppe und dann ballerst du da gefrorene Brokkoli, gefrorene Erbsen, gefrorenen Spinat, wahnsinnig viel gefrorenes Zeug rein und dann weisst du nicht mehr, ist das jetzt kalt oder warm, weil es war mal heiß, wird jetzt aber massiv runtergekühlt, weil da ist ja unglaublich viel Energie oder halt fehlende Energie durch dieses Frostzeug da drin. Ist Frost negative Energie? Ja. These. Ich habe gehofft, du antwortest darauf nicht. Und dann mache ich es nämlich immer so, dann sehe ich ja dem, dann weiß ich nicht mehr, ist es kalt oder heiß. Und dann nach einer gewissen Zeit tue ich meinen Finger in die Suppe und dann kann ich nicht das Ergebnis verwenden. Weil mein Gehirn denkt dann, oh, das ist bestimmt heiß. Und selbst wenn ich ganz kalt fühle, spüre ich es als heiß und andersrum. Das heißt, ich kann eigentlich dadurch nicht die Temperatur messen. Das ist aber auch ein spezieller Fall. Ich glaube nicht, dass das ein spezieller Fall ist. Ich glaube doch, dein Geist hat mittlerweile deinen Körper abgehängt. Ich glaube auch, ja. Die schreiben nicht mehr miteinander. Ich glaube, Sportler oder so, die würden sofort, die würden den Finger reinhalten und höhlenmenschmäßig sagen,
ho, ho, heiß. Nein, ich glaube,
ja, stimmt, mein Körper und mein Gehirn haben sich blockiert, gegenseitig auf Twitter,
die kriegen nicht mehr mit, was der andere
so macht. Da wird eine Mauer gebaut, das ist wie so Ost und West
Berlin, da ist eine Mauer inzwischen und
wenn jemand versucht, auf die andere Seite zu kommen, wird er erschossen.
Ja, aber das ist schon merkwürdig, weil das
ja auch wirklich, wenn du so
eine Badewanne hast und du weißt nicht, ob die
extrem kalt oder extrem heiß ist
und du tust deinen Fuß rein, du spielst ja nur
Vielen Dank. Ja, aber das ist schon merkwürdig, weil das ist ja auch wirklich, wenn du so eine Badewanne hast und du weißt nicht, ob die extrem kalt oder extrem heiß ist und du tust deinen Fuß rein, du spürst ja nur extrem. Der Fuß weiß erstmal nicht. Du weißt es erstmal nicht. Und das ist schon komisch, warum funktioniert Spüren so. Weil zum Beispiel jetzt, wenn du einen Lautsprecher hast und du sagst, da kommt jetzt gleich ein entweder extrem lauter oder extrem leiser Ton raus. Weil man weist sofort, was es ist. Nur bei Spüren ist es, also ich glaube, Spüren ist der schwächste Sinn vom Menschen. Ja, hier geht es ja nur quasi um so einen gewissen Delay. Aber es gibt ja tatsächlich... Man checkt dann nachher schon relativ schnell, ob es zu heiß oder zu kalt ist. Aber es gibt ja auch gewisse Sprachen, wo die Extremen dasselbe Wort haben, wo hoch und tief dasselbe heißt. Wo hot auch warm und heiß. Genau, wo du einfach nur, du hast einfach nur dieses Spektrum, aber das Wort selber sagt dir noch nicht, wo auf dem Spektrum es ist. Ich glaube, im Latein gibt es das sogar auch, hoch und tief, altos, glaube ich, ist das. Das heißt, wenn du sagst, du weißt nie, was gemeint ist, wenn du sagst, wow, der Berg ist ganz schön altus. Ja. Stimmt. Also was meinst du? Extrem. Niedrigus oder Horus oder wo sind wir gerade? Aber das, vielleicht kommt es daher, dass der Mensch manchmal so aufgebaut ist. Es ist ein bisschen wie so, kann man sich das vorstellen wie so ein Graf, so eine Parabel, weißt du? Und du sagst schon wieder Worte. Und nee, mit einem Scheitelpunkt unten und es läuft, an beiden Ecken läuft es exponentiell nach oben. Und weißt du, oben ist das Gefühl für Wärme und Kälte und unten ist für neutral. Ja. Und wenn du da reingehst mit dem Finger in die Suppe, weißt du nur, ob es gerade eine extreme Temperatur ist, aber du weißt erst mal nicht, du weißt Altus, aber du weißt, oder ob es neutral ist, du weißt aber nicht, in welche Richtung. Aber ich glaube schon, dass der Körper danach nach ein paar Sekunden relativ schnell checkt, ob es viel zu heiß oder viel zu kalt ist. Ich glaube, wenn du kein Gefühl hast, erst mal, wenn dann nicht sofort die Alarmlocken angehen in deinem Kopf, dann ist erst mal neutral, eine neutrale Temperatur. Ja, ist auf jeden Fall merkwürdig, aber macht Spaß irgendwie, so auftauen
macht mir richtig Freude. Hast du jetzt
mittlerweile viel Freude daran? Ich habe richtig viel Freude
daran, so dieses, sich vorzustellen, dass
was ganz Kaltes in was ganz Heisses reinfällt
und die müssen das dann
irgendwie ausdiskutieren, die kämpfen dann so,
die gucken sich das dann an und einer
gewinnt und der andere nicht. Ist so ein moderner Gladiatorenkampf
ein bisschen. In gewisser Weise schon. Hitze gegen Kälte, Miami Heat gegen Miami Freezing. Immer noch einer der besten Witze jemals, ich weiß nicht, von wem es kommt, aber ich würde lieber das, was dahinter steht, hinter den Namen kämpfen sehen. Giants gegen Bears. Giants gegen Bears, Heat gegen Jazz, fucking call me in.
Dimitri Martin.
Dimitri Martin, ja.
Immer wenn man nicht weiß, wer es ist, ist Dimitri Martin lustigerweise.
Ja, worüber wir auch wenig wissen, ist nicht nur die Welt der Temperaturen, heiß und kalt, hoch und tief, steile Thesen. Sondern auch tatsächlich Australien. Wir wissen nicht viel über Australien.
Deswegen unsere neue Rubrik.
Genau, wir wissen aber, ja, okay, jetzt müsste ich kurz schauen.
Mach kurz mal einen Känguru nach in der Zeit.
Ich habe noch nie in meinem Leben gehört.
How does a kangaroo make? Ist das wahrscheinlich ein krasser Song, der immer sehr berühmt war?
Was, wie macht ein Känguru? Ganz unironisch, gerade mal kurz. Rrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr wenn man auch noch springt dabei. Stimmt, hoch und, ja. Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow. Gibt es eigentlich so ein, also es gibt ja so Pferde-Wettrennen, gibt es nicht auch Känguru-Wettrennen, weil das würde ich mir anschauen. Pferde-Wettrennen sagt man ja. Man kann Wetten platzieren auf Pferde-Wettrennen. Aber das als Känguru-Wettrennen, das würde ich mir angucken. Und vor allem der Jockey sitzt dann vorne im Beutel drin und hat so ein kleines Lenkrad. Das finde ich eigentlich schlecht. Warum macht das Wort Wettrennen das sofort so klein? Usain Bolt gewinnt ja auch nicht beim Wettrennen, sondern beim Wettrennen klingt sofort... Ja, irgendwie klingt es kleiner. Wer zuerst hinten an Baum ist, hat gewonnen. Das klingt nach Wettrennen, wenn es das Pferde Wettrennen. Sebastian Vettel, Sie haben das letzte Wettrennen gewonnen. Nein, nicht den Grand Prix von Monaco gewonnen. Genau, eines dieser Wettrennen haben Sie gewonnen. Wir haben ja auch Wettrennen zu sagen, das macht es klein. Sie haben gewonnen, herzlichen Glückwunsch. Aber fände ich nicht schlecht. Warum eigentlich immer nur Pferde? Aber passt man in so einen Kängurubeutel rein eigentlich? Wir sind mal wieder da, okay. Ich weiß nicht, warum. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich da reinpasse. Ich würde nicht reinpassen, glaube ich. Es gibt Riesenkängurus, vielleicht passe ich da rein ein bisschen. Aber man kann Babys, glaube ich, reinsetzen, Kängurubeutel. Ich habe mich letztens intensiv mit Monstern befasst und es gibt ja tatsächlich ein Monster, das echt ist, dass man, also es gab lange diese Seemannslegenden, dass es diese riesigen Krakenmonster unter Wasser gibt, die die Schiffe in die Tiefe ziehen und solche Geschichten. Und irgendwann hat dann jemand gesagt, nee, ich habe aber sowas echt gesehen. Und dann hat die Meeresbüdie-Jungen gesagt, ja, ja. Andererseits die Piraten vorher, die gesagt haben, nee, ich habe es mir ausgedacht. Hat der gesagt, nee, ich habe es wirklich gesehen. Und die Meeresbüdie-Jungen so, nee, okay, arr, uu, grosses Monster. Und der so, nee, im Ernst, ich hatte das wirklich in meinem Fischernitz, so ein Riesending. Und die so, ja, egal. Und dann haben aber immer mehr Leute gesagt, nein, ich habe es wirklich echt gesehen. Und die Meeresbiologen, ja, okay, ein Riesenkraken unter Wasser, alles klar, blub, blub, blub. Bill Nye hat gesagt, fahren Sie da hin und finden Sie es selber nochmal.
Finden Sie es selber nochmal.
Und dann irgendwann haben die Meeresbiologen aber gesagt, Leute, da häufen sich jetzt wirklich die Berichte. Sollen wir das ernst nehmen oder sollen wir weiterhin die Leute auslachen und so dicke Backen machen, so blub, blub, blub unter Wasser, grosser Tintenfisch, ja wahrscheinlich. Natürlich. Es stellt sich heraus, es gibt es tatsächlich. Und irgendwann mussten die Meeresbiologen wirklich sagen, sorry, Lloyd, sorry, wir müssen das jetzt langsam ernst nehmen. Und es gibt Riesenkalmare, bis zu acht Meter lang, riesenlange Tentakeln, Riesenkopf. Ja, aber die greifen nicht dein Schiff an und ziehen dein Schiff in die Tiefe. Riesige Dinge mit einem kleinen Schiff, das Kajak. Die ziehen aber nicht dein Kajak in die Tiefe. Klar, die haben dein Kajak in der Hand und ziehen die runter, kein Problem. Die haben die Black Pearl, mein kleines Kajak, ich habe es Black Pearl genannt, in die Tiefe gezogen.
Die hat die Black Pearl in die Tiefe gezogen.
Da steht tatsächlich in dem Wikipedia-Eintrag von Riesenkalmar steht, das musste sich langsam erst in der Meeresbiologie durchsetzen, weil es viele Leute einfach nicht geglaubt haben.
Weil das ist das Problem, wenn jetzt wirklich ein Bigfoot auftaucht, sagen viele, ja, ja, okay, komm, hau ab jetzt. Wir sind eine ernsthafte Forschungseinheit, hau ab. Aber es gibt es tatsächlich, Riesenkalmar hat es tatsächlich gegeben. Und vielleicht ist es auch eine Art von Phänomen, dass sich wahre Dinge, die es schon als Legende gibt, erst gegen die Legende durchsetzen müssen, bevor sie wirklich geglaubt werden. Ja, das ist ein spannender Aspekt. Also wenn jetzt wirklich das Yeti-Monster entdeckt wird, wird es nicht einfach wie, oh, ein neuer Frosch, okay, schreiben wir auf, Frosch. Da fragt ja auch niemand, oh, wirklich ein blauer Frosch, der morgens blau und abends rot ist, sondern sagt, ja, Frosch ist weird, warum nicht? In gewisser Weise Wind in den Segeln von Verschwörungstheoretikern leider jetzt. Also das ist ein bisschen eine schwierige Haltung zu sagen. Okay, dann lass uns kurz mal Wind rausnehmen. Schalten wir kurz Wind raus, ja. Wind raus. Man muss es natürlich schon beweisen können. Du brauchst natürlich schon so ein Ding, schon so ein, weil das einzige Bild, das es von Riesenkalmanen gibt, ist von so einem dänischen Touristen, der sie am Strand gesehen hat und so Thumbs Up macht, neben dem Riesenkalmar. Das ist das einzige biologische Bild, das es gibt. Das ist halt im Buch, im Biologiebuch, ist der und Paul. Der hat einfach Thumbs-up. Paul hat Thumbs-up gegeben? In manchen Forschungsbildern ist er auch so rauszinsiert. Du hast ja keine Badehose an, mit so einer Bierflasche. Hä? Paul? Der macht so Hasenohren hinter dem Riesen-Kalmar. Das ist leider das einzige Bild, das wir haben. Damit müssen wir forschen. Und Grossteile sind verschwommen und Grossteile sind nicht zu sehen vom Kaimar. Es ist mehr Paul.
Es ist das Facebook-Profilbild von Paul, das einzige Bild, das es biologisch gibt vom fucking Riesenkaimar.
Das ist wie wenn du so auf Tinder immer so Gruppenfotos hast, wo einfach drei von vier geschwärzt sind und nur so eine unscharfe Gestalt im Hintergrund, dessen Arme so ganz awkward auf viel zu hohen Schultern hängen. Das bin ich. Das ist das beste Bild von dir? Okay, let me swipe you right, because this is a fucking awesome thing. Ja, nah, im Interesse, das will ich mir mal angucken. Nee, aber wirklich, das verstehe ich auch immer nicht, und es sieht auch immer so aus, als ob er die Frauen entführt hätte. Wenn ein Mann ist, der in so zwei Frauen ist, das sage ich, weil auf der Puffe-Penier.
Genau von dir gibt es genau dieses Bild, wo du einfach mal zwei Ladies abgeschleppt hast. Zwei Ladies im Arm hast, damals sehr gute Freundin von mir und seitdem verschwunden. So sieht es aus, so ein bisschen. Geschwärzt, verpixelte Gesichter und es sieht sofort aus wie, ja, er hat die umgebracht und jetzt suchen wir ihn. Ja. Also, an alle liebe, liebe Jungs da draußen, bitte nicht solche Bilder bei Tinder nehmen, weil das sieht immer ein bisschen unseriös aus. Man müsste ja stattdessen eigentlich so die Emoji-Variante nehmen, dass die dann irgendwie so über dem Gesicht so diesen Herzaugen-Emoji haben, damit es nicht ganz so creepy aussieht. Hast du das Bild auch ohne den Riesen, das Riesen-Emoji? Ja, ich habe den Tittenfisch-Emoji auf den Riesen-Kalmar gemacht. Das war mega lustig. Das macht keinen Sinn. Hast du das Rohbild noch? Nö. Nö. Ja. Und dann hast du einen riesigen Forschungskongress von Meeresbiologen, die eh schon keinen Bock haben. Unser Bio-Lehrbuch hat leider Gottes bei Riesen-Kalmar eigentlich nur ein Emoji von einem Riesen-Kalmar. Aber das nur am Rande, das musste sich erstmal lange durchsetzen,
weil viele Leute es nicht geglaubt haben.
Heißt aber, es gibt durchaus die Möglichkeit
für mich noch zu beweisen, dass es Bigfoot gibt.
Absolut. Und das Nessie.
Absolut, Bigfoot, Nessie sind
alle möglich und
viel Erfolg.
Aber Nessie haben doch auch viele Leute gesagt
und Nessie gibt es doch auch gute Bilder.
Ja, aber Nessie hat auch der, der das erste Foto gemacht auf dem Sterbebett gesagt hat, das ist ein Fake. Hat er gesagt auf dem Sterbebett? Hat er gesagt. Why? Ja, ich weiß auch nicht genau warum, aber der hat anscheinend irgendwie so ein kleines ... Und mit mir soll auch der Spaß an diesem Rätsel verschwinden. Ciao. Ja, das ist so das Letzte auf dem Sterbebett. Vielleicht hat er wirklich ein schlechtes Gewissen, dass so viele Leute dann Nessie-Hype und da kommen und da reinsteigen und das suchen und er die ganze Zeit gesagt hat, nee, das weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube, ich werde mir auch noch irgendwas überlegen. Das lässt mich ihm glauben, aber als ob es das wirklich gibt. Hätte er einen Ehrengrund, er will es schützen. Er will Nessie schützen. Und deswegen sagt er, es gibt es nicht. Warum sollte jemand, der die Welt geprankt hat, am Ende noch zugeben, dass es die Welt geprankt hat? Vor allem, nur weil man es am Sterbebett sagt, ist es deswegen nicht automatisch wahr. Ich glaube, ich sage an meinem Sterbebett, komm näher, e ist gleich mc hoch drei, das Bild von Nessie, das habe ich gemacht und es ist echt, äh, was?
Wie man stirbt.
Ja, man würde es sofort glauben. Dinge am Sterbebett kriegen ein bisschen Bedeutung. Ja, absolut. Man muss sich, und das geht an alle da draußen, bewusst sein, was man am Sterbebett von sich gibt. Ich glaube, das ist, also das ist glaube ich, was mich am meisten Angst vorm Sterben ist, dieser Moment, wenn alle dich so angucken mit so einem Zunicken, so ein ... Und so, ich hab nix, ich, sorry, ich hab Blackout. Ehrlich jetzt, du hast dein Leben lang Zeit. Du hast wortwörtlich dein Leben lang Zeit gehabt hierfür. Was hast du gemacht in der Zeit? Dieser Podcast? Also ist jetzt nur ... Also dann, okay, pass auf. Nur gemeinsam ist man stark. Gott, dafür habe ich Eintracht. Die wichtigsten Sachen sind unsichtbar. Hallo, wir sehen an dem Moment, dass du noch lebst. Nein, ja, ihr könnt gehen, lass mich in Ruhe. Wieso hast du nichts? Du hast doch, hier, wenn man mal guckt, zwischen 86 und 97 hast du eigentlich nichts gemacht. Da war doch gut Zeit, du hast überlegen. Da war ich, na ja, ich weiß auch nicht, da liefen gute Sachen auf YouTube. Ja. Na okay, gut, dann also jetzt, Achtung, schreibt jemand mit, letzte Worte. Nee, bislang war es noch nicht nötig, mitzuschreiben. Also ich würde, schaut euch nicht auch manchmal ein Basketballspiel an und denkt euch, es wäre viel besser, wenn die Dinge, nach denen die Mannschaften benannt sind, gegeneinander spielen.
Das ist die Mitrymaten. Das ist die Mitrymaten.
Ich wusste nicht, dass ihr das kennt.
Gut, wrap it up. Wrap it up, man. Okay, ihr wart ein gutes Publikum. Ciao, Leute, macht's gut. Passt auf euch auf und immer der Nase nach. Das ist super stressig. Super fucking stressig. Ey, dann lieber Busunfall. Wirklich, dann lieber schön aus dem fahrenden Bus ins Meer fallen. Ich will, glaube ich, auch nicht sterben, weil ich will nicht festgenagelt werden auf meine letzten Wörter. Nee, das will ich auch nicht machen. Und auf mein letztes Shirt, was ich anhabe. Vor allem das Tolle ist ja, ich habe glaube ich jetzt schon einige Tweets geschedult für 2080 oder so. Das heißt, meine letzten Worte werden eh Tweets von über Harry Potter, mittelmäßige Harry Potter Gags aus dem Jahr 2014 sein, die ich halt einfach nur wahnsinnig weit vorgeschedult habe. Das sind meine letzten Worte. Hast du wirklich Tweets geschedult? Ich glaube, ich habe noch ein paar Tweets geschedult. Ich habe sogar einen Account, zu dem ich keinen Zugriff mehr habe, bei dem ich auch Tweets geschedult habe, ziemlich weit in der Zukunft, und ich habe ein bisschen Angst, weil ich komme halt ... Die sind unzeitgemäss. Die sind unzeitgemäss. Die sind ungegaltet. Da sind halt noch viele Begriffe drin, die man heute so nicht mehr verwenden würde und viele Referenzen, die heute auch wenig Sinn ergeben, also noch so European Song Contest Gags, die halt am Abend der Show lustig sind. Warum sollte man nur auf 2079 schedule? Ja, ich dachte mir, ich habe heute schon drei Tweets rausgehauen zu ESC und jetzt lass uns den mal auf 2056 schedulen.
Und dann ist der Space-Urban-Song-Att du sagst, ha, das Kleid ist sehr durchsichtig. Ja, schwierig, aber vielleicht, ich hab mich ein bisschen verrannt damit, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Aber interessant eigentlich, kann man nicht tatsächlich so einen Droh, so einen Droh-Channel aufmachen, so einen Droh-Twitter-Account, wo man sagt, wenn du mir es nicht, wenn man belastendes Material hat. Oder kann man sich damit nicht selbst unter Druck setzen? Wenn ich nicht das und das mache, geht und dann muss ein Freund den Account pflegen und das Passwort einem nicht sagen. Und man schedult was in die Zukunft und wenn man gewisse Dinge nicht macht, postet der Account belastendes Material. Okay, also sozusagen,
wenn du dich nicht selber stellst,
wenn du nicht fünf Kilo abgenommen hast
in einem halben Jahr, dann postet dein
Account einen offensichtlich von dem
Mitry gemarnten, geklauten Gag. Ja.
So, und dann muss man selber...
Los! Lauf!
Lauf! Du musst abnehmen!
Lauf, los! Lauf!
Aber wie genau verhindert denn der Account dann, dass es gelöscht wird, wenn man es schafft? Rein technisch, wie kriegt man das denn hin? Ganz einen Account löschen oder halt einfach der Freund muss dann einspringen. Ja, gut, man kann es sich nicht selber hinkriegen. Druckmittel. Okay. Ja gut.
Worüber es auch manchmal Tweets gibt, ist ein ferner Kontinent, der uns seit jeher verzaubert, über den wir allerdings relativ...
Ich finde Australien immer noch super spannend.
Nein, wir reden über Afrika.
Ein ferner Kontinent, der uns verzaubert, über den wir aber sträflich wenig wissen, ist Afrika.
Afrika.
Und Afrika ist ein Kontinent im Süden Europas, der viele Dinge und Geheimnisse beinhaltet, die wir nicht kennen.
Und deswegen haben wir eine fantastische Brick ins Leben gerufen, die nennt sich Antenne Afrika. Herzlich willkommen bei Antenne Afrika, wir stellen uns jedes Mal ein Land aus Afrika vor richtig gehört, Afrika ist kein Land, sondern Afrika. Genau, wir haben schon viele Länder besucht, zum Beispiel Uganda, zum Beispiel, nur um einen zu
nennen. Um einen zu nennen, Uganda haben wir
schon besucht. Und heute schauen
wir in ein weiteres fantastisches Land, mit dem
ich tatsächlich schon Erfahrung gemacht habe,
denn in unserer Schule
gab es ein
Projekt, das wir
Geld gesammelt haben für dieses Land,
es ist nämlich Togo. So, und ist es
da angekommen oder ist es in deiner Tasche gelandet? Das weiß ich nicht,
das erhoffe ich mir jetzt aus diesem Beitrag,
der eingeschickt wurde von
Vielen Dank. Geld gesammelt haben für dieses Land. Es ist nämlich Togo. Und ist es da angekommen oder ist es in deiner Tasche geladen? Das weiß ich nicht, das erhoffe ich mir jetzt aus diesem Beitrag, der eingeschickt wurde von Leonhard, der was weiß über Togo. Und ich hoffe, dass ein Satz fällt wie, ja zum Glück hat damals die siebte Klasse, die sieben A aus dem Gymnasium Geld gesammelt. Deswegen sind jetzt hier alle Probleme gelöst. Vielen, vielen Dank nochmal an euch, ohne euch wäre das nicht möglich gewesen. Mal schauen, was Benedikt, was Leonard zum Bericht hinweist aus Togo. Moin Stefan und Lorentin, wir befinden gerade in Palime, einer kleinen Stadt im Landesinneren von Togo. Hauptstadt von Togo ist allerdings Lome am Atlantik. Togo ist umgeben von Ghana, Binnen und Burkina Faso und ist von der Fläche her einer der kleinsten Länder Afrikas, hat aber meiner Meinung nach das größte Wortwitzpotential.
Amtssprache ist, was Florentin sicher freuen wird, Französisch, allerdings wird im Alltag meist westafrikanischen Sprachen gesprochen wie Ewe oder Kabin. Das war die Band Unity, die vor allem traditionelle westafrikanische Musik macht, welche neben Reggae und Pop auf französischen Ewe sehr beliebt ist. Togo war bis 1960 französische Kolonie, davor war es bis 1914, also bis zum Ausdruck des Erstenkriegs, deutsche Kolonie. Zum Fortbewegen benutzt man in Togo meistens Motors, Taxis und Busse, wobei Taxis und Busse meistens überfüllt sind. Bezahlt wird in Togo mit dem Franc CFA, das ist eine Währung, die in vielen anderen westafrikanischen Ländern auch angewendet wird, ein Euro sind ungefähr 665 Franc CFA. Beliebtes Essen in Togo ist der Yams, das sieht ein bisschen aus wie eine übergrosse Kartoffel und wird zu vielen verschiedenen Gerichten verarbeitet, wie zum Beispiel Fufo, wo der Yams da stampft wird und da mit Chava-Sauce gegessen wird. Auch noch sehr beliebt sind Gerichte aus Mais, Maniok, Bohnen und Nudeln. Sehr beliebt in Togo sind Kleidung aus bunten Stoffen, die man sich am Markt kaufen und dann lässt man sich die bei einem Schneider zu Hemden oder Hosen oder Kleidern nähen. Zu Weihnachten kann ich hier noch nicht so viel sagen, wird aber auf jeden Fall von togolesischen Christen hier gefeiert, da könnte ich einfach noch etwas nachreichen. Neben Christen gibt es in Togo noch Moslems und einige traditionelle westafrikanische Religionen wie der Voodoo-Religion. Jetzt kommt noch ein Interview mit dem Leiter der togolesischen NGO, International Volontaire en Nation, welcher mit togolesischen und europäischen Freiwilligen zusammenarbeitet und unter anderem Sensitierungsprojekte durchzuführen
und darüber hinaus auch in Kinheim unterstützt. My name is Perel, I'm a Togolist, and you know Togo is a country between Ghana and Benin, and if you come to Togo it is like you visit old Africa, and here the country is a very peaceful country and many people from Europe come to visit the country. And I invite everybody to come and visit our beautiful country. Me, for example, I am a coordinator of an organization and we promote intercultural exchange. So we welcome volunteers from Europe,llo, miadogolo, das bedeutet, wir werden uns in Togo treffen. Ja, es gibt auch wirklich immer diesen, ja, Land X war eine französische Kolonie, tutum tutum tutum tutum tutum, war immer die Trommel ein, aber vielen, vielen Dank.
Wie toll! Ja, es gibt auch wirklich immer diesen, ja, Land X war eine französische Kolonie, du dumm, du dumist, einmal quer durch diesen faszinierenden Kontinent, wir haben gesehen Burkina Faso. Zum Beispiel. Und es werden noch viele andere dabei sein. Ruanda. Ägypten? Nein. Falls ihr auch tolle Beiträge einsenden wollt, schickt sie uns. Wir haben keinerlei Möglichkeit, die Dinge, die ihr sagt, zu überprüfen. Von daher ... Wir warten auch auf das erste ausgedachte Land. Wir vertrauen da auf euch, dass ihr da keinen Quatsch erzählt. Dankeschön, das war ... Antenne Afrika! So, wir sind wieder zurück. Wir sind aus der kleinen Flugkapsel gestiegen. Und wir sind wieder zurück. Und zwar möchte ich noch ganz kurz ein paar Einsendungen kommentieren. Es geht nämlich um die letzte Folge, da haben wir die Spiegel-Bestsellerliste kommentiert und dazu gab es auch einige Hausaufgaben, die wir gegeben haben. Wir wollen nämlich natürlich diese literarische Welt bereichern, wir wollen sie weiterentwickeln.
Und es wurden natürlich einige Titel vorgestellt letzte Woche, die zufallsgeneriert waren, sowohl die Titel als auch die Autorinnen und Autoren. Und dazu hat Lena sich gemeldet, die hat das Ganze weiterentwickelt. Und zwar hat sie, wir haben gesagt, wir möchten ja zu den einzelnen Titeln Texte haben, die uns ein bisschen weiter nahe bringen. Und Lena hat sich dem literarischen Genre des Haikus angenommen.
Und sie hat zwei der Titel in Haikus verwandelt.
Die Weiterentwicklung von Pikachu.
Ja, was ist ein Haiku? Ein Haiku ist ein kurzes Gedicht, das kürzeste Gedicht der Welt, sagt man, damit passt es natürlich wunderbar. In diesem Podcast, wir lieben kurze Dinge. Schön knackig kurz, so gefällt uns das. Und die Struktur eines Haikus ist immer 575. Also das ist natürlich schwer zu übersetzen, weil es ja natürlich aus dem Japanischen kommt mit diesen Zeichen. Das heisst, es ist nicht immer ganz leicht zu übersetzen, aber Lena, so habe ich das verstanden, hat es immer nach fünf Wörter, sieben Wörter, fünf Wörter System gemacht. Und sie verarbeitet hier natürlich den grossen Erfolg, wir haben es letzte Woche gehört, Platte Tüte von Elvira Wohlraab verarbeitet sie hier als Haiku. Hemarkt, fertig, ab nach Hause. Zuhause ist meine Katze einsam und allein, kaum drinnen, schon platte Tüte. Das war der Haiku, äh das Haiku, und sie hat auch einen weiteren Knaller verarbeitet, und zwar welche Motte von Marlon Nerz hier als Haiku.
Klamotten, lecker lecker Auswahl vorhanden, Hose, Shirt, Bluse, Rock, Kleid, Pullover, Shorts, viele Motte wollen es essen.
Als kleiner Bonus kommt noch ein drittes Haiku hinterher, und zwar natürlich, so wollen wir es immer haben, so stellen wir es uns vor, das Crossover-Heiku, wo einfach nochmal alles zusammengeflossen wird. Und hier das Crossover-Heiku von Lena, die schreibt, Krawumms, Krach, Krawauts, Bang, Buff, Wunde Kanten, heisere Hummeln, platte Tüte, obskure Nachrichten, schlotternde Rinden, Büffel. Vielen, vielen Dank für diese drei Heikus von Lena. Wenn ihr jetzt zuschaltet, wir sind das Podcast-UFO, wenn ihr gerade nicht mitgekommen seid, dann ist das kein Problem. Fangt einfach an bei Folge 1, dann hört euch langsam chronologisch durch. Generell eine gute Idee, glaube ich, um Keep Up, Keeping Up. Ja, vielen Dank, Anena, für diese fantastischen Haikus. Ein tolles Genre, ein tolles Genre der Lyrik, das sich vielleicht zu erforschen lohnt. Wir haben ja schon ein paar Limericks gehört letzte Woche, jetzt kommen die Haikus. Ich bin gespannt, welche Genres es noch gibt, die wir verarbeiten können. Ja, ich muss leider auch eine Storyline weiterführen. Das ist ausgerechnet, dass ich es machen muss. Das ist ein bisschen unglücklich jetzt. Ich verabscheue diese Storyline. Ich bin der Meinung, da sollte einfach mal einen Haken hinter dran. Und wir hören alle einfach auf, uns mit dem Thema zu beschäftigen. Ich muss es trotzdem tun. Ein Hörer hat mir eine Nachricht auf Instagram zukommen lassen. Es geht noch mal um Dinosaurier. Denn... Oh nein! Wollen wir das wirklich hören? Wollen wir nicht ... Forscher?
Nein! Nein, hör auf jetzt!
Nein, nicht Sandalen!
Forscher haben herausgefunden.
Nicht Schwimmflügel! Du musst da jetzt durch!
Nein!
Du musst da jetzt wirklich durch.
Nachdem wir Federn, Pferdeschwänze, Crocs, lange graue Haare, Bio-Lehrer-Look, alles Verträgungslehrer, wir sind alle schon durch. Sitz falschrum auf dem Stuhl, Beine gespreizt. Das hatten wir alle schon, das ist alles schon bestätigt. Ich hasse Forscher. Das ist alles schon, Dinos waren das alles schon. So. Was jetzt kommt, Forscher haben herausgefunden, dass es nicht unbedingt gesagt ist, dass nur weil das Skelett so aussieht, wie es aussieht, heißt es nicht, dass darum nicht noch wahnsinnig viel fett war. Oder, weil, Beispiel, Florentin, kannst du dich mal kurz, Beispiel ist Walskelett. Nein, Ich will keine molligen Dinosaurier.
Nee, das Wort ist nicht mollig, das Wort ist blubbery.
Keine Blubber-Dinosaurier.
Wale sind ja auch wahnsinnig aufgequollen und blubbery,
obwohl das Skelett ja eigentlich relativ sleek ist.
Das Skelett müsst ihr eigentlich annehmen, so wie wir Dinosaurier wahrnehmen.
Jetzt habe ich ein Bild für dich, das hängen wir an in die Folge, aber wahrscheinlich sahen Dinosaurier so aus.
Nein, das ist ein Bullshit. Nein, das ist ein April-Scherz. Nein. As CM Cozman explains throughout all yesterdays, we really can't ever know, how much fat and other soft tissues contributed to the overall shape of dinosaurs, since that's the first thing to rot and shrivel tight against their bones, and like even a sperm whale has a little skinny skeleton so like Bild. Dieses Bild ist eine Frechheit. Das ist wirklich eine Frechheit. Es sieht ein bisschen aus wie Barney, der Dinosaurier. Es sieht generell aus wie ein Maskottchen, eigentlich süsses Maskottchen. Es sieht aus wie ein Dinosaurier in einem Kostüm. Und guck mal, was aus dem Gebiss wird. Es ist ein Doppelkitten. Es ist ... Ach, Stefan. Ach Mensch, das ... Die coolen Dinos. Aber das heißt doch nicht, dass sie nicht cool aussehen. Wale sehen auch cool aus. Wale sehen nicht cool aus. Nilpferd ist auch cool und ist ein bisschen kräftiger. Nashorn. Nashorn ist cool. Nashorn ist cool, weil die Panzer haben. Aber wenn die so dick aufgekommen sind, die sind aus, hätte man Stoff, die nur im Wasser vergessen. Macht sie doch noch viel riesiger und eindrucksvoller, wie die gestampft haben müssen. Stampf, stampf, stampf. Aber es ist süss. Ja, es ist schon... Es sieht niedlich aus. Und wenn die dann noch Federn haben, ist es ja wirklich so... Also das ist ja eher Küken-Look. Riesige Küken liefen über den Planeten. Natürlich hat das Universum gesagt, da bombardieren wir den Planeten jetzt mit Meteoren. Das ist so albern. Das ist definitiv albern. Das war die beste Entscheidung eigentlich. Ihr war ein riesen Kuschelfest am Start. Riesige Lebebäden. Kuschelige Sachen. Ich meine Federn, also unterschätzt Federn nicht. So eine Eule ist fucking kuschelig. Also wirklich, vergiss mal gerade Kätzchen oder so, Federn sind eigentlich das kuschligere Organ oder was auch immer. Wir kommen langsam von hier war ein riesen Monster Freak Show hin zu, nee, das war so süss, Planet Erde war niedlich, riesige Bäume mit so grossen bunten Blüten und dann so blubbery Dinosaurier. Schön Federfell, vielleicht Schnabel, wir wissen es nicht, vielleicht einfach ein riesiges Hühnchen. Riesige Hühnchen mit fluffigen Federn und so dicke, klobige Dinosaurier. Oh, fuck. Zu grossen Mündern und zu riesengroßen Lächeln. Ja, mit menschlichen Zähnen. Oh Gott. Aber das ist auch, also ich bin gespannt, wann das Natural History Museum da auch wirklich entweder sich abspaltet und sagt, Nee,, vergesst es, wir sind jetzt eher sowas wie eine Geisterbahn und bleiben einfach beim alten Modell der Dinosaurier, weil du ziehst ja irgendwann keine, ich meine, 80 Prozent der Leute im Natural History Museum kommen wegen dem riesen T-Rex in der Mitte der grossen Ausstellungshalle, weil der cool aussieht. Aber wenn da jetzt irgendwie so ein Flabberwesen noch drumherum ist, wo du einfach sagst, der ist ganz gemütlich, der hat eher so einen Panda-Bär-Look, ein großer Panda-Bär mit Federn, es ist hart, es ist hart.
Die Genuss waren mal cool und irgendwann werden sie vergessen, weil die süss waren.
Man wird es langsam sagen, die Genuss verlieren einfach an Coolness, das ist crazy.
Und wir gucken dabei zu. Wir können gerade dabei zugucken, wie wir Jahrmillionen auf dem Planeten, wie die egal werden. Das waren große Monster. Stell dir vor, Jurassic Park mit riesen Blubbery Felby. Blubbery ist auch kein gutes Wort, da muss man auch andere Wörter, Powerful, Giant, sowas, da kam Blubbery. Was hattest du nochmal gesagt, Schuppen hatten die? Äh, die hatten wie Paillettenschuppen. Also schimmernde Paillette. Schimmernde Paillette. So ein riesen sassy Planet. Also es ist ein bisschen eine laufende Disco-Kugel mit Federn dran. Und Blubbery. Und die wahrscheinlich auch nicht so furchteinflössend gerohrt haben wie so ein Löwe sondern halt eher wie ein Küken recht hoch mama aber können wir nicht die Forschung auch mal in die andere Richtung treiben können wir nicht ein bisschen Geld in die Hand nehmen und sagen nee forscht mal lieber in die andere Richtung dass sie vielleicht so Hörner haben oder coole Stacheln oder der eine hat ein Schwert genau ein ein Schwert vielleicht, eine Peitsche oder Feuerspucken. Aber macht das besser? Macht es, wenn eine riesige... Ah, der eine hat Räder, der eine hat Räder irgendwie so, Räder noch dran. Ganz im Ernst, das macht es fast süsser, wenn dieser grosse, das grosse Küken mit Disco-Kugel-Pajetten Feuer speien kann, würde ich sagen, ich würde nicht an dem bestimmt Angst haben, ich würde sagen, oh, cool. Ja, aber vielleicht, ich weiß es nicht, dass die dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, so Säure spucken können oder irgendwie dann sich so verdoppeln können oder so. Oder dann, Stefan, du guckst mich so enttäuscht an, es tut mir leid, aber... Mir reicht's. Komm raus aus der Rubrik, raus aus Dino-Update. Fucking! Kann doch nicht wahr sein. Dino, Dino, Dino! Ich bin gespannt, wann Jurassic Park auch da endlich nachzieht.
Und vielleicht das Remake von Jurassic Park
dann wirklich mit diesen grossen freundlichen Dinos,
die so aussehen wie diese, wie Barney.
Wie Barney das flauschige Monster.
War Barney ein Dino oder war Barney ein freundliches Monster?
Weiss man oft nicht, es fliesst alles zusammen.
Alles verschwommen.
Ja, ist alles verschwommen. Meine Vergangenheit ist ein grosser Blurry-Brei.
Ja?
Die gesamte Vergangenheit oder deine persönliche Vergangenheit?
Meine persönliche Vergangenheit, ich erkenne mich an nichts erinnern, richtig.
2018?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich sehr gemacht habe.
2018 im Speziellen weiß ich nicht.
Bei mir ist alles ein grosser, so ein verschwommener, so wie wenn man in so einem öffentlich-rechtlichen Beitrag diesen Effekt drauflegt, wenn man sich besoffen ist. Ach so, ja. Die Kamera schwankt so ein bisschen. Das heißt, wenn wir deine Autobiografie lesen, ist auch abschnittweise, boah Leute, also kein Plan. Aber auch so viele Gegenfragen so, aber erinnert ihr euch denn immer an die Scheiss-Detail-Hofen? Also ob ihr jetzt sagen könnt, was ihr gemacht habt, als ihr 14 wart. Vielleicht war es in Hamburg, vielleicht war es in Berlin, vielleicht war es in Frankfurt, ich weiß es nicht. Keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht. Da war doch niemand, war da nicht die Quatsch, ich war im Urlaub, war ich nicht im Urlaub. Mit der D, mit der Dings, mit der Dings, der, ähm, also, Stephans ehrliche Biografie. Herr Tietze, vielen Dank für die erste Version Ihrer Autobiografie, aber ich glaube, da kann man viel kürzen. Also, Sie scheinen sich ja nicht an viel zu erinnern. Ja, aber wenn Sie es kürzen, dann bleibt doch nichts über. Genau, das ist nämlich unser Problem ein bisschen. Wie hat jemals jemand eine Biografie geschrieben? Ja, naja, wir hatten zum Beispiel diesen einen, ähm, ach Gott, wie hieß der denn? Sie erinnern sich selber nicht mehr an alles. Der hieß, nein, also, nee, war das nicht, nee, Quatsch, das war ein Film nicht. Ben Hur! Ja, Ben Hur! Nee, wir hatten ja die Biografie von Markus Müller-Wester, Mario Werner Müller-ller-Zhagen. Der hat zum Beispiel geschrieben, der hat als ... Oh Gott, ich weiß auch gerade nicht. Wie entstehen Biografien? Ich weiß es nicht. Du musst ja theoretisch die ganze Zeit anfangen, schon ein Tagebuch zu führen. Sonst hättest du ja keine Chance. Ja, es stimmt schon. Oder ich weiß nicht. Oder ein Podcast machen. Ghostwriter. Denn jede Woche einen Podcast aufnehmen hilft, um langfristig zu checken, was man die Woche macht. Du kannst einfach jetzt 2018 zurückspulen und die Podcast-Folge aus 2018 anhören und weißt, was du gemacht hast. Was du damals für Sorgen hattest mit deinem dummen Fisch und den ganzen Pflanzen und die ganzen Kratzeis. Wo man auch denkt, ich habe einfach nichts erlebt. Was habe ich vor drei Jahren? Nur Nonsens erlebt. Nonsens bestellt. Vor drei Jahren habe ich kiloweise Kratzeis zu meiner Post bestellt. Stimmt, du kannst auch über Amazon. Eigentlich sind unsere Leben schon ganz gut dokumentiert. Mit Twitter und Amazon-Bestellungen und auch mal YouTube nochmal zurückscrollen. Was hat man sich damals angeguckt? Allein so die Foto-App, wenn man da so rumscrollt. Das mache ich manchmal an so einem schönen verhekteten Sonntagag, einfach ein bisschen durch die Foto-App scrollen, was man da entdeckt, das ist teilweise richtig schön. Kleiner Erinnerungsausflug. Und teilweise grauenhaft. Und viele Screenshots. Viele versehnliche Screenshots. Ich mache auch ganz viele Fotos aus Versehen, wo ich nicht weiß, das sieht aus wie eine Geiselname, war ich dann ein Geisel? Waren sie nicht verschwommen in einem Zug anschein Irgendwie ganz verschwommene Gesichter? Das sieht aus wie eine Doku, als wärst du in Nordkorea mit Knopfkamera unterwegs gewesen. Und dann denke ich mir, Moment mal, war ich Spion? War ich Spion? Haben die irgendwann mir so Drohungen gegeben, dass ich vergesse, was ich in der Zeit gemacht habe? Ach nee, ich bin einfach nur aus Versehen auf ein Foto auslösen Knopf gekommen. Sorry, war ich mir nicht mehr sicher. Mittlerweile habe ich die Doku zu Ende geschaut. Der Maulwurf. Der Maulwurf in Nordkorea, Dänen in Nordkorea. Däne in Nordkorea. Ihr wusstet nie, dass ihr es wollt, aber ihr wollt es. Ihr wollt das Crossover, ihr wollt Dänemark und Nordkorea Crossover haben. Fantastisch, was eine unglaubliche Doku, wo auch Afrika eine Rolle spielt. Oh, sehr gut, da können ja dann unsere Zuhörer haben schon einen kleinen Vorsprung. Die können schon ein bisschen überspringen. Nee, wir sind skippen. Und das ist die Kultur in Burkina Faso und alle Podcast-Überzuschauer nur, diese zwei Minuten meines Lebens kriege ich kostenlos oben drauf, ich skipp zwei Minuten. Burkina Faso habe ich schon durchgespielt, habe ich schon gelernt. Wir hoffen, dass ihr eine fantastische Woche habt. Sie wird grossartig für viele von euch. Für ein paar von euch furchtbar statistisch gesehen. Statistisch gesehen. Wir gönnen euch es nicht, aber wir können es auch nicht verhindern. Aber ich glaube, ihr kommt da durch.
Und ansonsten, viele hören den Podcast auch gar nicht aktuell, sondern hören den Podcast vielleicht im Jahre 2023.
Vielleicht hört ihr diesen Podcast gerade am 7. Aber ich glaube, er kommt da durch. Ansonsten, viele hören den Podcast auch gar nicht aktuell, sondern hören den Podcast vielleicht im Jahre 2023.
Vielleicht hört ihr diesen Podcast gerade am 7. September 1923.
Toi, toi, toi.
Oder am 7. September 2023.
Falls ihr das tut, denkt euch, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich damals so gute Woche hatte.
Go Ruth!
Ist mir egal.
Ruth, die Präsidentschaftskandidatin der USA.
Go Ruth!
Wir wünschen euch ganz viel
Spaß, habt eine tolle Woche, ansonsten haut rein,
wir heben ab, macht's gut, bis dahin, ciao.